hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich sitz hier mal wieder
zusammen mit sandra weil ich benötigt
worden denn hey du hast du selber
verbockt darauf mein lieblingsort
langsam hatten
[Applaus]
ich glaube leute das ist san marino
ich sage auch
so das ist malta
was sagen wie viel haben wir richtig
also wenn die deutsche flagge kommt bin
ich mir sicher dass die eigenschaften
farbcode ein herzlich keine jetzt schon
ich bin froh dass es nicht unsere flagge
ist weiß nicht warum es nicht einfach
kreativere flaggen gibt es gibt so
kreative fußball wappen aber dass du
kannst es macht man einfach nur damit
einfach ist ja für mich ist also kuba
ist cobra lieber
das ist armenien
marokko oder
island das ist alles
[Musik]
weg ist dann glaube ich
dass
luca sich die verraten
ja das ist kambodscha
ich kenne die figuren kambodscha
es ist
die flagge von der nasa für mich oder so
ein es sieht aus wie china ist aber
nicht nur japan
ich glaube das ist lettland das los
geht's
der wachmann stellen von jerusalem ich
glaube ich dass es auch jerusalem es ein
bisschen enttäuscht dass es vietnam
afrika jetzt nächstes afrika das ist
südafrika sondern ja ja das sind zwei
verschiedene länder ja wie unnötig
afrika südafrika dann raffen greifen
kontinent
und das ist so wie wenn du sagst europa
und deutschland sind zwei verschiedene
länder so
spektakulär es gibt nun uci etwas new
zealand als kontinent
ist
doch schön
[Musik]
ihr land
rot-rot bist du farbenblind
mir das ist das ist auch irgendwas bei
russland ich würde sagen das ist libyen
das ist bulgarien wo
das sieht aus wie ein hütchen um mit
cäsar
südkurier war ein geschrumpftes profil
ich glaube das ist
ja auch zypern
das ist richtig
du hast von mir schon gedanken gelesen
deswegen sagst du die antwort das ist
kasachstan bleiben ich weiß dass das was
rumänien
das wundert mexiko nehmen dass rumänien
karastan lees das ist der rumänische art
lag das ist rumänien
das moldawien
dass bulgarien das ist moldawien
bulgarien
doch wie
gesagt
[Musik]
hey das ist ja genau das gleiche die
haben einfach flagge kopiert mit adler
darauf geben was es als wäre die wahl
des
ccc nein klar italien ist so hochkant
das ist nein das ist afghanistan oder
irgendwie sowas oder irak iran irgendwie
sowas ist dass ich sage ich mag dass
iran ist sehe ich sage es ist gott land
das ist ungarn
tja so müll das ist die russland
schlagen mit sticker drauf
dass die russland flagge
mit rumänien moldawien
weißrussland
will ich auch sagen weissrussland
slowakei
ja knapp daneben ist auch vorbei war
knapp daneben ist auch vorbei
ist
ja das ist auch richtig
das ist richtig dritter punkt nein ich
pack dagegen konnten einfach nicht ein
junges holen kannst du auf und englisch
zu reden das ist polen danke dass du
doch mal übersetzen hast ja das ist
polen das auch okay wir machen direkt
weiter mit der nächsten frage meine
lieben freunde das ist nämlich diese
hier ukraine ukraine ja
das ist richtig eine gemeinsame laufe
die leute auch dass sie nichts
aber ich sage es nicht die bottom fahrer
gas gab nordkorea
das korrekt danke danke wir machen
weiter mit der nächsten frage und da
haben wir russland
wir sind gut mittlerweile leid ich
stecke mir nicht einen ekligen toten
mein gesicht ist dass griechenland mehr
spaß
das ist überhaupt nicht griechenland ich
lerne hier dieses weiß blaue kreuz noch
drin hieß es dass das ist san marino das
ist halt marine ja das ist kuba
die hübsche frage ich liebe
resident
monaco monaco
neuseeland
peru
weißt du ich dachte du bist du von dem
man in der schule ab schreibt konnte
argentinien argentinien du bist so
nachmacher
meldet die ich werde mich in der schule
ich werde im sommer meldet sich in dem
moment auch ich sagen 17 donnerstag 17
argentinien
[Musik]
sind wir so scheiße ja
das ist richtig aber das kam mir gesagt
dass sie kommende wunderschönes in den
letzten drei flaggen
die sich vermalt warum ist das so
das ist weißrussland kolumbien
kommen zur letzten frage meine lieben
freunde frankreich
wir haben es
luca wir können nicht klappt schon das
ist so peinlich
ich setze mich heute erst mal hin mit
einem atlas alter druck nicht als länder
nach alter ich habe gar keine atlas aber
mich hat auch google bleibt es raus
sucht raussuchen